so then a question for you so you think
the individual should have the choice
to have access to wheat ecstasy cocaine
crack uh all these drugs heroin
so
not
a free-for-all if you are suffering from
a substance use disorder because you're
addicted to heroin
there are modalities out there that you
should be able to access which includes
a safe supply of drugs heroin assistance
treatment therapeutic so it depends on
the drug
you know
our organization doesn't believe in
anarchy but we understand
that
the harms of criminalization is what's
fueling the illicit market the violence
so it's okay so you're not saying
legalizing all the drugs that's not what
you're i'm saying sensibly regulating
which is just another term for maybe
legalizing but it shouldn't be you know
anarchy there is
you keep saying anarchy what do you mean
by like you can just walk in and buy
you know
methamphetamine wherever you are what
should should the way i buy
metamphetamine is the same way i buy
based on a doctor prescribing it to me
where i can just go to cvs and buy it
off the counter
i mean isn't that what happens so so
your suggestion is
to make it sensibly
uh not legal what's the word you're
supposedly regulating
sensibly regulated is the same way i am
prescribed vicodin
it could be it depends on the process it
depends on the drug but you're not
saying i go to the mall and i just buy
it correct okay fair okay so that's what
you're doing but cannabis you can
as an adult yeah you know so you know
what it makes me think about them this
goes kind of to you because of a point
he made so
so why is it that we're
the death toll
for legalized drugs is higher than
illegal drugs let me unpack this and i
want to ask you because he just made a
good point and i was actually going to
push it on you but then you flipped it
and i'm going to sure put it on her so
opioids okay
i mean nowadays
you want it you get it people are dying
it's going higher and higher now they're
giving it to kids kids are starting to
take it now i mean i i have four kids
kids are not going through this i lived
in a city called plano the story of
plano what it used to be is a whole
story of what happened there with these
kids that were being handed drugs out in
the next thing you know anyways that's a
completely different story but opioids
is that a hundred thousand cigarettes
you know how many people died last year
from cigarettes 480. 480 000 people died
from cigarettes yesterday that's one in
five everybody one in five death last
year was tied to cigarettes that's the
number right there more than 480 000
deaths annually from smoking and
secondhand smoke okay i mean when you
hear a statistic like that philip morris
legal you know vicodin xanax all this
stuff legal so
where i would say we need to make
vicodin illegal we need to make some of
these things tougher to get a hold of
doc many of these guys that are drug
dealers going to jail some of these
doctors should be going to jail for the
work that they're doing thank you so
this flip said that if we made it more
easier to get accessible
folks who are in sales they're going and
dropping the packets off to the doctors
and nowadays they can bribe the doctors
hey i'll give you ten thousand dollar
speaking fee twenty thousand dollar
speaking fee if you start prescribing
this stuff that's an additional income
to the doctor doctors trying to make
money to have a s500 parked outside next
thing you know these pharmaceutical
companies are doing advertisement on
national television television
television televised the networks oh my
god you know and by the way there are
risks could cause death this would cause
us but you should use it and they give a
nice pretty face that's using it so
that could also that's also a good point
that if we do that the marketers are
going to go out there and figure out a
way to profit off of these things so
we're only one of two countries that
allows
prescription pharmacies to advertise on
television
you're against it i'm totally against
pharmacists or farmers pharmacy
companies and corporate
but let's let's go back to this right
now in the united states i'm sorry you
said one of two countries one of two
countries
i can't remember
the other but i think that
we're one of two countries that that
allow advertising i don't think cannabis
should be advertised on tv i don't think
tobacco should
or alcohol even new zealand here we go
okay so we're the only two countries and
i think that's part of the issue is
americans you know
tend to think that popping a pill is
going to solve everything but i also
don't think that making things illegal
stops people from trying something you
know what does public health
interventions and education does look at
what we've done with teen smoking is
down
like i just pulled in and i'd have to go
back and take a look at them is the
stats for
drug use amongst teenagers like the kids
are all right the sky isn't falling
they're not having sex they're not
smoking wheat as much they're not
drinking they're not smoking cigarettes
they're not using other drugs
i think we need to stop looking because
of you guys or because of smartphone and
all the distractions
who knows it's a it's a bunch it's you
know we don't have kids getting pregnant
as much as they used to because we
taught them you think that's what it is
anything because of social media
i think there's a lot of different
things but i think that that harm
reduction you know let's talk about
those words is really giving people the
skills to critically analyze what
they're putting in their bodies whether
it's a prescription look i've had
multiple surgeries i've had two broken
ankle surgeries i've had two knee
surgeries i've you know have eight
bulging discs in my neck and my back i
have used plenty of opioids and and i've
had plenty of surgeries i've had
oxycontin
i'm
really not the av or i'm more than the
average person it's it's unusual for
people to get addicted to opioids based
on surgery yes it occurs
you know but it's not as prevalent and
so you know
we look at you know the fentanyl deaths
i'm gonna go back it's not pharmacy
fentanyl that's killing people right now
it's mexican cartel illicit fentanyl
that's coming in
from across our border if you enjoyed
this short clip give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch the whole thing click over here